if you two were charmed by the
mysteriously titled project code Zed
heading your way from square enix you'll
be happy to hear the veil has been
lifted and potentially less happy to
hear that it's a ps4 exclusive game
called spelunker which is totally not
spelunky the game entitled me Nerdist
Poloncarz said is set to land in japan
on march 18 and is being developed by
toes like games whose repertoire also
includes a bunch of other spongy games
now I know you're probably watching the
trailer here and thinking this looked
terribly spelunky asked but squares game
is based on the original salunkhe game
which was released in 1983 so if
anything's a monkey looks terribly
spelunker s the upcoming spelunker will
offer you the same 2d run around with
treasure grubbing rope climbing and cave
exploring so if you like that kind of
thing you'll be right at home the game
is going to be free to play and there's
no word on a Western release as yet let
me know if you're keen for this one or
if you were hoping for a different
Square Enix game to come out of this
teaser project will keep you updated as
this one develops so stay tuned against
what